Hey youtubers, it's Charlie!
This week for my Game of Thrones Bonus video
I wanted to talk about White Walkers.
Something really cool happened on the set,
so this is going to be a little speculation
based on past experience.
So the really cool thing that happened is
that the people that shot the big White Walker
scenes last year during hardhome are heading
to the sets, so they're actually getting ready
to do some white walkers stuff now because
we haven't read winds of winter we're kind
of in unspoiled territory so a lot of this
is going to be speculation based on stuff
they been setting up in the previous books
and previous seasons of the show so just careful
for spoilers for everything this happen on
the show so far and new round of the giveaway
starts now it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so here
we go what are some of the biggest things
that could happen with white walkers in episode
10 will the nights king could show up at the
wall or we could just get a really ominous
scene that deepens the mythology of white
walkers there's still so much that we don't
know about the great other but we we don't
know really anything about their culture George
RR Martin just hasn't written in the end someone
actually asked them previously if they have
culture and he's like I'm I'm not sure I mean
this is like a year ago so he made change
that since then but if you ever weren't sure
there are certain things that George R Martin
makes up as he goes along I mean he has a
pretty good idea where he wants the characters
ahead like he knows about the character arcs
but there are certain things that he thinks
of as he goes along that's why by the time
the characters get to a dream is spring break
to be doing vastly different things than the
characters on the show do in season eight
but just looking back at previous seasons
episode 10 has typically been reserved for
wrapping up storylines in a way that throws
into next season you still get some big reveals
like last season aria went blind with the
closest thing we've had to a big battle in
episode 10 with Stan is going up against the
Bolton's and that really wasn't much of a
big battle it was more of the lambs going
to slaughter actually in season 4 when Stannis
showed up with the sellswords, that was a
bigger battle because it was actual fighting
but does that mean we get to see a White Walker
version of what happened to Stannis at the
end of season five, will the white walkers
just show up and eat whatever army is near
the wall not necessarily but I do like the
idea that they would end with the big White
Walker victory at the end of season six just
to try and avoid rampant spoilers is that
you are supposed to be a big battle in the
north that could lead to like a really high
moment for good characters so why not and
honor really WTF down moment when white walkers
completely destroy something that I will say
I think it's a little early for the wall to
be coming down but I but I do think that they
would do that WTF moment the thing is is that
the local government where the wall scenes
are filmed wants game of thrones want HBO
to keep the wall up so they can use it as
a tourist attraction is just super popular
I mean of course people want to go visit the
wall so I think they're going to try and leave
it up as long as possible but I do think it
is certain point like they'll be that epic
CG moment where the nights king just brings
it crashing down it's kind like watching the
Golden Harpy come tumbling down the pyramid
during season five anytime a story presented
like this big shiny symbol of power of course
it has to come tumbling down it is certain
point but it's white walkers do make it to
the wall and there's a battle in and around
that area than what does that mean for season
71 a means of their victorious of course to
get a push south during season seven in and
I said in the past I think I would love to
see the nearshore but like the end of season
seven so that season they can be like this
giant prolonged battle season the law that
would just depend on the pacing of season
six like will just have to wait we get episodes
to see how fast are trying to speed things
along and they really wanted to I mean they
could stretch it out like 12 seasons but they
were they said they don't want to do that
so I guess it just depends on how literal
you think the nurses visions from the house
in the undying are like she makes it to the
iron throne but it's covered in falling snow
so that would mean that white walkers a pushed
very far south by the time dinners gets to
west roast I try not to be too literal when
it comes to things like that I definitely
think we'll see white walkers in the South
like they'll be the reason for all the people
that each other in west roast to come together
to remember to nurses visions were also of
things that could have happened had things
been different but she saw future vision of
her baby Ray go the one who is not the world
but we know he's dead will call that game
of thrones earth two the most of what I'm
hoping with this by Walker stuff in episode
10 you do whatever ends up going on is that
was gonna see a lot of White Walker stuff
in season seven as of where we are in the
books right now winter has already come so
the further south that it pushes like the
colder and colder it gets the more white walkers
we have to see I know some of you vest me
in the past like if the white walkers bring
the cold or if they follow the cold in and
I think it's the cyclical relationship like
there's general climate change in the white
walkers and just taking advantage of that
but there might also be some magic in play
we don't know quite how powerful the nights
king is only the he has amassed powers of
necromancy not any White Walker can raise
a white the nights king is just presumably
more powerful like he can just raise several
all the same time in there have been a lot
of theories about what can happen with the
nights king and it is going to be some sort
of truce in the final battle I definitely
think there will be an absolute final victory
like that just being the white walkers back
to the lands of boys winter just to talk about
this character here are the nights king that
they use during episode eight George R Martin
clarified that the classic nights king the
13th lord commander is probably dead so the
term nights king if you want to use that is
like a title that gets passed down it just
used to distinguish this character from the
other white walkers get the nights king then
you have normal white walkers then you have
all the whites that they've raised to serve
them and for those you that are still holding
out for benjen this is the actor the place
that nights king that they used so he'll probably
be back in season eight definitely not Joseph
mawle looks absolutely nothing like the actor
that plays Benjen but the really cool thing
about all this is that they're bringing Bran
Stark back were getting a lot of brand scenes
were getting a lot of bloodraven scenes so
that will probably tie in with what's going
on with these white walkers the bloodraven
is one of the few characters we we haven't
seen a whole lot with them yet he's one of
the few characters is lived long enough to
accumulate the knowledge that we need like
we as the audience in that the characters
need in order to fight the white walkers so
everybody get height and here's my big question
if you let me know what do you think that
episode 10 White Walker stuff is going to
be a big battle like what's happening with
Stannis the last two seasons or do you think
it just going to be an ominous revealed like
that just show up at the wall and then bam
slammed the black white as thing about that
I'll say congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner's Dennis the Menace brassy and it was
actually an HBO reveal about what's going
on with your character I don't want to write
your just because it's super spoiler rebutted
it pretty much definitively answers whether
he is alive or dead please Stannis, private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact info.
just in case you guys haven't seen it whole
bunch of Star Wars stuff has been going on
the last week I posted a couple trailers you
can click here to see all those and you can
click here for all my game of thrones season
six bonus videos thank you so much for watching,
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tonight!